you are such a busy guy
how busy am i well you're so busy that
you're constantly working
of course in television but you've got
these hilarious podcasts
i went on uh yes you were so kind to
come on smartlist
i came on smart was because it's you
it's mr
uh will arnett and uh jason bateman
yeah um i just do that
he said very little the whole time i
have to say that guy's coasting on that
podcast
but uh you guys were hilarious oh thanks
yeah no you were very very nice to come
on if you haven't checked it out check
it out the conceit is that one of us
acts as a host
and brings on a guest that the other two
don't know about so it's all through
zoom
so the guest covers up their camera or
they put like a little posted on it and
we introduce them and they reveal
themselves
to the other two very good thing and
then uh i was
i wasn't quite talking to some people
recently oh i was done with it okay yeah
i i i just decide when the i've been
doing this so long i decide
when the anecdote's over and i just go
okay okay i'd love to come back
anyway
[Laughter]
i was going to say a nice thing which is
that i guess you had stephen colbert on
and he told some crazy story about me
which is insane and not in the realm of
possibility
well anyway i'm just saying he does he
feels differently
he feels differently and um and uh i
think the story has me on a ski lift
yeah what am i doing on the ski lift i
love that he's acting like he's not he
doesn't know
oh i thought you told me about i was no
i had heard about him you pulled your
pants down in front of a group of
children and you
shat on them yes yes stephen colbert
tells this story because what's true is
that he and i
were skiing once together and we were on
a ski lift and then and and suspended in
the air and he
tells this insane story about me taking
my pants off on the ski lift
and then uh defecating on children who
are sitting below
okay fantastic so i run into these
people this is a couple of weeks ago i
run into these people and they said
children no not the children it was the
children and they're like they're
covered um no i ran into these very nice
people who are chatting they recognize
me and they start chatting with me they
went oh my god we were listening to the
funniest podcast
and stephen colbert told me this story
about and they told the thing that
stephen had said and i'm laughing really
hard and going yeah yeah and then they
stopped and they went
is it true and i was like yes
i just decided to say yes it's true
because you can't deny that no of course
what are you talking about i took my
pants off and pooped on people on a ski
lift
well i mean you're doing a very well job
of acting like you didn't do it now
listen
but just think the control it would take
the aim yeah
that's the part that's what you even
described the pants you were wearing
with the secret panel in the back that
comes down for ease
that's right true that is true
anyway i love these people relating this
story to me about me on a public ski
lift
pooping on people below and laughing and
then they're like is it true
wait but did you listen to it did you
listen to that episode you have to
listen i didn't listen to the episode
if i listen to every episode of every
podcast where i'm name checked
and talked about with great reference oh
so famous is this i'm a so famous story
i'm sorry it's not possible there's not
enough time in the day because you're so
popular
exactly thank you